and finally major headline here Babylon
B Matt Walsh jumps out of the bushes at
Easter egg hunt to inform the kids that
bunnies laying eggs is biologically
impossible
now
I appreciated this story this is like I
think it's the fifth or sixth time I've
been uh mocked
ruthlessly by Babylon B and uh which I
which hurts my feelings deeply of course
but I also appreciate it
but then my second question was
who tells their kids that the Easter
Bunny lays the eggs is that what people
are being told
I never now
yeah this is this is I didn't know
here's the thing I didn't know that this
was the kind of falsehood I needed to
correct so that's the only thing that
this story gets wrong is that I wouldn't
be going up to kids and say you know
Easter Bunny doesn't lay doesn't lay
eggs because I never knew that really
that's what you're telling is that what
parents are telling kids that the Easter
Bunny actually lays the eggs like a
chicken
the Easter Bunny thing has always been
you know as you know I'm a Santa Claus
apologist you know I I I'm fully on
board with the Santa Claus thing Easter
Bunny's always been a little too weird a
little too disturbing
even when I was a kid I I always thought
that I was kind of like my parents told
me about this big giant bunny that shows
up
and you know leaves a basket somewhere
comes into the house at least
and I I always had so many questions
about this thing where does this thing
come from we don't have the same with
with with uh Santa Claus there's this
whole whole mythology around we don't
have the Easter Bunny so I've always
thought it was kind of strange I didn't
know that that kids were also being told
that this mutant uh sorcerer east bunny
lays eggs I always when I was a kid I
always thought that the Easter Bunny he
has the eggs and it's like in a basket
and he hides them places
the story is getting even more
disturbing than I thought but I'll do it
for this portion of shows we move over
to the members block hope to see you
there if you uh want to join us you can
become a member and use code walls to
check out for two months free on all
your new plans hope to see you there if
not talk to you on Monday have a great
Happy Blessed Easter
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]